- [Norm] Let me ask you a
seemingly simple question.
I have a picture of fire
here, and my question is,
what is fire?
Well, what would you say if
I were to tell you that fire,
as we see it, these flickering flames,
it is nothing but hot air?
And I know what you might be thinking.
Hot air?
"Norm, I've seen air that's hot,
or I experienced air that's hot
and I don't oftentimes even see the air,
but here I clearly see something bright,
something that's emitting light,
something that's emitting
electromagnetic radiation."
And then what I would say to you,
if you were thinking that,
is it actually turns out
that anything in our universe
that has a temperature above
absolute zero, zero Kelvin,
which is pretty much anything
that you will ever come
across in your life,
emits electromagnetic radiation.
Objects with temperature
aren't the only way
to create electromagnetic radiation,
but it is a major way that's
happening all around us.
Even if you were in a pitch-black room,
you would be emitting
electromagnetic radiation.
A tree outside, even
if it was dark outside,
is emitting electromagnetic radiation.
You might say, "Wait, but
I don't see the tree,"
and that's because your eyes
can only detect certain frequencies
of electromagnetic radiation.
If we look at this
diagram right over here,
we can see how we've categorized
many of the frequencies,
and you can see that up here,
this is the frequency,
this is the wavelength,
and these are in powers of 10.
So you can really view this
as a logarithmic scale.
And just over here,
you can see that our
eyes can only visibly see
a small section of this
logarithmic scale of frequencies.
One of the things I like to wonder,
if humans didn't have eyes,
if we weren't able to detect
even the small segment
of the electromagnetic spectrum,
would we even know
that something like
electromagnetic waves existed?
But we can see you have
gamma rays, x-rays, UV rays,
infrared rays, microwave,
FM, AM radio waves,
long radio waves.
In most hot air,
the frequency isn't high
enough for us to see it.
So most hot air is going to
be in the infrared range.
Only if it gets hot enough
will we start to see it,
and that's what's happening
with this fire here.
And if you look closely at a fire,
you might actually see that the location
where the combustion
reaction is happening,
that that actually might be dark.
And then right above that,
you'll see some blue flame,
and then you'll see,
maybe if you look closely,
some green or yellow flame,
and then you will see the orange flame,
and then you will see the red flame.
And the reason why it
might be dark right where
the combustion reaction is happening
is that might be very high
energy electromagnetic waves.
That would be in the UV spectrum.
That would be at a higher
frequency than what's visible,
so to our eyes, it looks dark.
And then as it cools, it goes
through the visible spectrum.
And then if it cools
enough, it goes to infrared.
But we human beings have
built the capability
to see beyond what our
regular eyes can see.
For example,
these are what are often
known as thermal images,
but they're really just
detecting the infrared range.
So this is a picture of two dogs.
It could be pitch-black outside.
I mean, it could be the
middle of the night,
but because they have temperature,
they are releasing electromagnetic waves,
which we can detect.
And this over here has a scale
of what the temperature must be.
So you can see the eyes of the dog
are the hottest part right over here.
You can also see thermal
imaging of not only a hand,
but after a hand has touched a wall.
With our eyes, if you were to touch a wall
for say 30 seconds,
it doesn't look like the
wall has changed at all,
but if you were to look at the infrared,
you would see that you
would have heated up parts
of the wall and you would be able
to see the shape of the hand.
And so you can imagine, we human beings,
because of our ability to
detect electromagnetic waves
and explore electromagnetic waves,
we've been able to
leverage them more and more
in our everyday lives.
Thermal imaging itself
has a lot of applications.
Firefighters use it to find people,
or to find flames in the
middle of a lot of smoke.
We have things like x-rays,
which are high energy
electromagnetic waves,
which we can use to see
through soft tissues.
So we can see bones.
This is an old image and
it looks like they're using
the x-rays kind of carelessly.
You don't wanna be throwing
that radiation around,
but even today.
I got an x-ray of my
teeth just the other day
when I went to the dentist.
When you talk on your cell phone,
the way that your cell
phone is able to communicate
is leveraging electromagnetic waves.
This is another thing
that's mind blowing to me,
is that my little cell phone
can actually emit electromagnetic waves
in the radio part of
the spectrum far enough
to be received by a cell
tower that could be 10,
20, and in certain cases,
30 or 40 miles away.
Microwave ovens literally
released microwaves,
which are absorbed by our
food, which heats up the food.
And so I'll leave you there.
The big picture here is
that electromagnetic waves
are all around us.
It's most obvious to us
in the visible spectrum,
because that's what we can see.
But there is a large continuum
of different frequencies
that the visible is only a part of.
And we human beings have
leveraged this phenomenon
in all sorts of interesting ways,
and I would suspect that
we're just at the beginning
of this exploration.
Maybe you will come up
with a new application
of electromagnetic waves.